Jim Acosta has the day off.
You are in the CNN newsroom.
We begin this hour with breaking
news.
Former president Jimmy Carter is
receiving hospice care at his
home in plains, Georgia.
Sources tell CNN president Biden
is staying in close contact with
the family.
Let's go now to CNN's Jeff
Zeleny in Washington.
What more have you learned since
we've just heard this not too
long ago.
>> We are learning this this
afternoon and the Carter center
advised something we had not
known, the former president has
had a brief series of hospital
stays.
He made the decision to spend
his final days to enter hospice
care in plains, Georgia.
That is really so extraordinary
because that of course is where
the former president has sent
his entire life with the
exception, of course, of his
four years here in Washington at
the white house as well as his
military service as a young man.
He went home to plains, Georgia,
in his post-presidency, and
that's where he's been ever
since.
With rose Lynn, his wife at his
side for 77 years of marriage or
so.
So the family is saying that he
is going to be in hospice care,
and we are also learning just a
short time ago, we heard from
his grandson, a former Georgia
state senator, a gubernatorial
candidate, who is basically in
the family business in Georgia,
Jason Carter, and he said he
visited with his grandparents
yesterday in plains.
He tweets this.
I saw both of my grandparents
yesterday.
They're at peace, and as always,
their home is full of love.
Thank you for all of your kind
words.
As I'm talking to you, former
advisers to the Carter family,
they're really keeping a close
hold on his impact held
condition.
Instead, they are choosing to
talk about his life, really his
extraordinary legacy from peanut
farmer to the presidency, and it
was really the post presidency,
the last half century nearly of
his work that has been so
extraordinary, and he's been a
Sunday schoolteacher, a parade
of people we're seeing right
here now, his plains, Georgia,
church.
He's greeting visitors,
something he always did, if he
was on an airplane, he was known
to be shaking hands with
passengers up and down the
aisle.
He taught Sunday school, built
homes for habitat for humanity,
particularly in the wake of
hurricane Katrina.
I certainly remember that well.
Clearly now, president Biden,
I'm told, has been advised of
this, and he is in close contact
as well, and some interesting
history between those men as
well.
President Biden paid a visit to
the Carters on the 100th day of
his presidency, back in 2021,
and then senator Joe Biden was
the first senator to endorse the
Carter presidential bid, back in
1976.
So they have a long history
there.
I'm told the white house is in
close contact.
They share some actual former
advisers.
Anita Dunn was a young adviser
to Jimmy Carter, all thoughts
are with the Carters.
For now, he has chosen to remain
in plains, Georgia, the
epicenter of his life, his
legacy felt around the world,
Sarah.
>> I have to say, I met him when
I was in college.
I know many of you have met and
talked to them.
He was gracious, he was kind.
He was giving.
It was remarkable to be in his
presence because of all the
things he's done, not just being
the president.
Really it's the post presidency
work.
Lots of prayers for his family.
Jeff Zeleny, thank you so much
for joining us.
>>> Let's turn to kye burr,
author of "The unfinished
presidency of Jimmy Carter,"
when was the last time you were
able to speak and see the former
president and how was he doing
at that time?
>> The last time I saw
presidential Carter was July of
2021 at his 75th wedding
anniversary, which was a gala
event in plains, where he
invited 350 colleagues and
friends and politicians like
Nancy Pelosi and Bill Clinton,
and you know, he had just had a
fall that week a few days
earlier.
Gashed his forehead, had many
stitches, but he was determined
to make the event, and he sat
there in a wheelchair, and
greeted each and every one of
us, and spent a few minutes
talking to everyone.
He just has an amazing stamina
and love of life.
He's an incredible force of
nation.
>> Yeah, I think that's a really
good way, he's an incredible
force of nature, he does it with
such kindness and compassion.
It really is remarkable.
A little bit about his sort of
family history.
I understand that pancreatic
cancer ended up killing many of
his close relatives, but not Mr.
Carter.
How do you think all of this has
impacted his life, having seen
others go through cancer and
dying from it?
>> Yeah, you know, all of his
father, Ms. Lilian, his mother,
all of his siblings, incoming
Billy Carter, they all died of
pancreatic cancer.
It was rather unusual, so
unusual that the national health
institute made a study of the
family to figure out what was
going on.
But he escaped this cancer.
And has led a very vigorous
life.
He did come down with melanoma
in 2015.
Just as I was beginning my
biography, the outlier, on him.
And he had this, if you recall,
he had this amazing press
conference live at the Carter
center, where he got up on
stage, and gave the news very
calmly, rationally, said that he
had brain cancer, melanoma that
had spread from his liver, and
he probably had just a few weeks
to live.
Well, of course we all know he
then got immune therapy and
survived and beat the cancer.
He is a survivor.
So.
>> He's a remarkable person.
Would you agree with a lot of
the assessment, you know, he's
still here with us.
He's still living, he has been
through I don't know how many
different things that for many
people has been the end for
them, but he has survived it.
75 years of marriage, as you
mentioned, and that was in 2021,
did you say?
>> 2021, right.
So that was 18 months ago.
>> And we're looking at
pictures, I think, of his
family, which is quite large,
and they're all laughing, and
they're all sharing time
together.
But I do want to ask you
about -- a little bit about him
and post presidency, most people
when they think of Jimmy Carter,
he was a one-term president,
which in the political world is
not necessarily the most
successful presidency, but in
the life after wards.
He's done remarkable things that
have impacted people's lives.
Can you talk a little bit about
that.
>> I argue in my biography, his
presidency, his four years was
quite successful.
He accomplished quite a bit.
But I also wrote that he sort of
tongue and cheek was the only
president who used the white
house as a stepping-stone to
greater things.
And it's true, you know, he had
a remarkable ex-presidency.
Just a continuation of his
presidency in many ways, doing
good works, so, you know, he
often joked that at the Carter
center that he wanted to live
longer than the last Guinea
worm, and the Carter center has
spent decades now, wiping occupy
millions of cases of Guinea worm
disease, a terrible affliction,
and they're now, I think, in
2022, we're only 13 cases in
human beings of Guinea worm
disease so he's almost made it.
>> Thank you so much for sharing
your insights.
You're the author of "The
outlier, the unfinished